[Música]
alguna vez tuvieron una idea un proyecto
algo que quisieron ceder o hacer
piénsenlo por un segundo
seguramente lo planificaron un montón de
tiempo lo trabajaron lo soñaron y el
problema aparece cuando deciden
contárselo a esa persona en la que tanto
confían como decirle a sus padres mamá
papá quiere ser influencia
y ahí te dicen no vos estás loca de que
pensabas vivir que pensabas hacer de que
vas a comer eso no se puede hacer bueno
lo que esto que pasó astor piazzolla
luego conocen y escucharon su música es
un compositor de tango argentino y desde
muy chiquito estuvo estrechamente ligado
a la música su papá a los 6 años la real
en bandoneón y a los 11 estaba
componiendo su primer tango y en el
momento en el ambiente la música lo
conocí a carlos gardel y gádor le dijo
vos el fuelle te tocas valoro pero el
tango lo tocas como un gallego
en realidad no es que no sabía tocar el
tango sino que lo entendía de otra
manera desde entonces luchó para
cambiarlo a pesar de saber que en
argentina se podría cambiar todo menos
saltando él decidió innovar de todas
maneras poniendo instrumentos eléctricos
en sus composiciones y si bien esto
generó un rechazo muy fuerte entre los
tangueros más tradicionalistas fue su
componente diferenciador por esta manera
de innovar sobre todo en lo eléctrico
y también por seguir sus propios ideales
sin dejarse llevar por la corriente
vimos que teníamos bastante en común con
astor y por eso se llamó así nuestro
proyecto pero eso lo entendimos después
de un largo camino largo camino somos
diseñadores industriales recibidos del
agua y para un proyecto de una materia
anual los otros meses teníamos que hacer
un proyecto desde cero desde la idea
hasta fin de año tener un prototipo
funcional que anduviera y el primer día
de clase los docentes dijeron bueno cuál
es su proyecto les dijimos que íbamos a
hacer un auto un auto eléctrico
seguramente se imaginaba en algo como
esto un super auto eléctrico y en
realidad nos imaginábamos algo el
chiquito para la ciudad es algo sencillo
y que nos dijeron que no nos tiramos
nuevas columnas que quizás no íbamos a
llegar con los tiempos con la plata o
que no teníamos los conocimientos nos
están diciendo que eso no se puede hacer
pero bueno nosotros ya nos esperábamos
esa respuesta nos imaginamos y medio
antes empezamos a trabajar en el
proyecto y ya teníamos más certezas que
dudas hicimos estudios de campo
encuestas analizamos la movilidad en la
ciudad de buenos aires y en otras
grandes ciudades y detectamos que la
movilidad estaba en crisis entonces
[Música]
para que sean y den buenos aires sólo
circulan por día un millón y medio de
autos el 80 por ciento estos autos va
con una sola persona imagínense la
contaminación y el espacio que ocupa
cada uno
entonces para resolver esta problemática
nos parece lo más sustentable diseñar un
auto eléctrico para la ciudad así que
demostramos que teníamos conocimientos
sustentos y no les quedó otra que
aceptar que sigamos digamos ya sabíamos
más o menos que en que nos estábamos
metiendo aunque no sabíamos que dar
tanto trabajo en realidad no fuimos sólo
nosotros dos los que trabajamos en el
proyecto ya también medio año antes de
empezar la cursada habíamos estado
formando el grupo de trabajo
era fundamental que nos conociéramos nos
entendamos y saber qué roles y
capacidades podría cumplir cada uno
también formamos las ideas y era muy
importante estar estar todos alineados y
en esta búsqueda de ideas nos cruzamos
con gabriel muñoz que es un fabricante
de bicis eléctricas de la plata y él nos
ayudó con el motor las baterías y
también con sus conocimientos en el
rubro que nos ayudaron a avanzar para
nosotros fue muy importante tener con
una empresa que te van que te ayude
desde el principio porque te da un
impulso muy grande y en eso ya teníamos
una idea pensada de una estructura en
madera de cómo estabas avanzando el
proyecto y teníamos que ir a los fierros
necesitábamos armar la estructura la
mecánica y se me ocurrió hablar con el
equipo para que contactemos a gabriel
torch ya daba
que le había restaurado el auto antiguo
a un amigo mío yo sinceramente por ser
un restaurador pensé que no iba a poder
ayudarnos con algo nuevo algo distinto o
un proyecto que no existía bueno yo
decidí llamarlo igual y fue encontrarnos
en un bar en el barrio de boedo para al
instante darnos cuenta que era la
persona indicada no solo estaba muy
entusiasmado en el proyecto dibujando ya
en la mesa sino que nos dimos cuenta que
era de esas personas que jamás nos iba a
decir eso no se puede hacer si están en
peligro de extinción es ese tipo de
mecánicos porque cualquier idea que les
llevamos él le busca una solución y así
sigue siendo hasta hoy en día
entonces con él terminamos de formar un
grupo de trabajo que podría resolver las
necesidades del producto como soldar el
chasis o fabricar piezas nuevas
incorporar las que venían estándar y
también como proyecto de la facultad
podíamos resolver las láminas hacer
ensayos y los planos que habría que
cumplir bueno estoy a mitad de año
teníamos que mostrar los avances del
proyecto en la cátedra entonces
agarramos la estructura la cargamos en
el ascensor hasta la entrada en el
ascensor de la facultad colgamos los
planos y pasaba el jefe de cátedra
corrigiendo y firmando los planes de
cada equipo hasta que sea nuestro lo
mira nos mira se cruzó de brazos me dijo
la vuelta y se fue sí loco pero con un
orgullo y sabiendo que estábamos
haciendo las cosas bien
éramos inimputable
bueno otro tema muy importante que
tuvimos que superar en nuestro proyecto
fue no dejarnos llevar por los
preconceptos bueno cuando pensaste que
abriéndonos ya puedes ayudar con la
estructura creo que fue un preconcepto y
de ahí tuve que superar prejuicios y
pudimos ir adelante con el que nos ayudó
un montón en todo lo que desarrollamos
como decía con esto de los preconceptos
uno muy importante que se da en la
industria automotriz es cuáles son los
pasos o las etapas para desarrollar un
auto por lo general se va desde las
ideas los dibujos los conceptos y
después se baja el producto real que
vemos en la calle
nosotros entendemos que este proceso
puede ser distinto yo por ejemplo el
chiquito me fascinaba dibujar autos me
pasaba todo el día dibujando
y eso me llevó a la carrera de diseño
industrial ahí entendí que el proceso
para diseñar un auto podía hacer para
diseñar un producto cualquiera sea
podría ser distinto en diferentes etapas
después entré a trabajar en la industria
automotriz y ahí me di cuenta que como
le pasaba todos los días sola en la
industria se puede modificar todo menos
el diseño de un auto por más que sea un
tema funcional sea un cambio entre la
carrera de un modo distinto cuando era
chiquita sabía que mi papá que es una
especie de inventor le quería poner
tornillos a todas sus cuestiones para
solucionarlas en la en realidad lo que
hacía era priorizar la funcionalidad y
después la estética veía cómo quedaba
pero estos detalles encontró la
funcionalidad relacionado al diseño
fueron los que hicieron que nosotros
encaramos el proyecto de un lugar
distinto pensando primero las
necesidades las personas porque sabemos
que la estética después iba a decantar y
ahí entonces surgieron los detalles como
las dimensiones 2 metros 10 x 120 la
distribución de los asientos en diagonal
pensando en la movilidad digamos en la
manera de acceder y en la movilidad de
las personas movilidad reducida y para
que las personas entienden esta manera
diferente diseñar un auto
tuvimos que justificar cada decisión que
tomábamos entonces trabajamos duro en
conseguir las evidencias de que
estábamos trabajando en función de las
necesidades personas y eso se vio
reflejado cuando lo terminamos que se
podían subir nuestros abuelos y también
personas de todas las edades y veían lo
práctico y cómodo que era para subir y
también lo fácil que era para manejar lo
bueno incluso tres de los integrantes de
equipo manejamos porque es un auto en el
actor
incluida y fue muy fácil porque me subí
me arranqué fue como si hubiera manejado
toda la vida
bueno ya está ahí parece que fue todo
color de rosa pero en realidad en el
medio en el proceso hubo prócer para
definir las ideas o algunas piezas que
se nos volaron y se golpearon se
rompieron otras que se nos perdieron y
al final las teníamos guardadas o que se
te queme el motor a las 3 de la mañana
la noche anterior a entre ellas
imagínense cómo estábamos teníamos que
entregar a las 11 de la mañana bueno por
suerte ahí estaba la persona que estaba
conectando el motor y en el baúl de su
auto tenía un motor de bicicleta
eléctrica que adentro tenía el mismo
repuesto que se nos había quemado así
que mientras estábamos al borde del
llanto él fue busco la busco la pieza la
desarmó armó el nuestro y astor volvió a
la vida
y así llegamos a la entrega entre
vientos mareas y tormentas que casi nos
agarran en la avenida general paz fue
literal agarramos al actor los fuimos al
remolque salieron para la facultad
rogando de que no se la regala llover
porque todos nuestro esfuerzo no se
podía mojar y llegamos a la universidad
nos dimos cuenta que nos faltaban subir
180 escalones a la sala de exposiciones
entre el cielo negro y truenos
si en realidad no eran 180 eran 38
pero parecían 180 y bueno
habíamos pensado casi todo durante el
año pero nos faltaron esos últimos
escalones que teníamos que subir para
llegar los
entonces alguno planteo y está dentro de
la facultad a buscar unas tablas para
usar de rampa y subirlo pero teníamos la
tormenta acá que se nos estaba viniendo
encima así que todos los que estábamos
ahí empezamos a empujar también la gente
que pasaba y bueno yo iba manejando un
valiente
pero los nervios que tenía eran inmensos
y aún así pudimos llegar como la
luchamos todo el año de hoy y fue
increíble porque fue atravesar la puerta
de la facultad que explotó un trueno muy
fuerte que dio paso a la lluvia y a
nuestra emoción que brotó allí porque
fue como el claro reflejo de todo ese
esfuerzo que veníamos gestando y impactó
en el último escalando el recorrido
bueno y eso lo pudimos lograr porque nos
esforzamos un montón durante el año y
también trabajamos muchísimo fueron
nosotros tres últimos meses viéndonos
todos los días después del trabajo
juntarnos
trabajar dormir tres horas por noche de
lunes a lunes y también festejar algunos
cumpleaños entre piezas del autor
cuando nos queríamos ver más la cara
pero la verdad que la gratificación y la
emoción que te genera adversidad con tus
objetivos
te dan orgullo indescriptible como
recibirte o tener un hijo
de repente ves todo ese esfuerzo
plasmado y te paras un minuto a
reflexionar todo lo que enfrentaste te
das cuenta que el esfuerzo que es así ya
lleva sacado durante tanto tiempo nada
valía la pena lo volvería a hacer y
también te das cuenta que todas esas
personas que te decían que no vamos a
llegar con los tiempos o que no se podía
hacer al final terminamos maravillada si
les encanta y te das cuenta que
estuviste siempre en el camino correcto
entonces volviendo a sus ideas a esas
que dejaron en el camino tiradas o las
que estén por venir les proponemos que
estén preparados para enfrentarlas a
todas estas personas que les puedan
decir que que no se puede hacer también
ármense de un grupo de personas que los
ayuden a impulsarse que jehová que no
los ayuden a ir adelante y sobre todo
que sigan sus propias ideas sin dejarse
llevar por la corriente es increíble
cuando pones tanto energía y te
esfuerzas en esas metas que te pusiste
todo se empieza a alinear entonces vayan
a su búsqueda armen desarme sigan
avanzando con sus ideas no se lleguen a
su bastón porque es muy bueno entonces
nos surge la necesidad proponerles que
piensen que pueden hacer hoy por sus
ideas
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]